assalamu alaykum warahmatullahi better
care to brothers and sisters in their
friends welcome to this video hope you
guys are doing well
now one of the righteous deeds to do is
also water plants and Allah it's really
important it's come to my attention
above and sisters and I thought this is
actually the perfect time to do this
video and now reason being now brothers
and sisters when it comes to the Dawa
and obviously sorry before I start that
a funny thing or praise His glory and
gratitude we don't allah subhanho wa
taala for all the work that we do so
yeah this is good shall i start with the
name of allah subhanho wa taala
Dawa is not for everybody now the topic
here today we're gonna discuss the
reason being I'm gonna talk and listen
to the free audio clips that I've been
holding on to for the past two to about
two to three years now when it comes to
tower lots of people thing and this is
actually this important is what I when
it comes to the matter of knowledge
seeking knowledge is something that's
really important
now some people have knowledge some
people have knowledge but are arrogant
some people are arrogant but do not have
knowledge and some are some don't have
knowledge and is arrogant and some you
have you have knowledge and it's not a
written if that makes sense yeah so now
we need to understand that when it comes
to the tower it's really really
important not just our in general as
Muslims being Muslims is very very
important how we conduct ourselves our
o'clock and manners is really important
in mime admit when he would give a talk
thirty thousand people would come they
would say and about ten thousand will
come to seek knowledge and twenty
thousand will come to observe his months
a clerk and man it was something the
Prophet peace be upon him stressed on so
much that's why he said imagine this he
said I did come I did not confer nothing
except a perfect good character why did
the Prophet peace be upon him emphasized
so much why did he in a rate that the
two of the things that are gonna be
heavy on the day of judgment on the
scales is gonna be toe he and someone's
good o'clock good manners why was this
so much emphasized
we're gonna find out why that is
inshallah in this video now brothers and
sisters doubt a lot of people get doubt
in different ways but to think that
doubts are only things that you hear
that you hear and then you have these
doubts I have to debate to disagree let
me tell you why when certain people when
we look at let's see a certain group
who's misrepresenting Islam is making
Islam look bad whose harsh certain
groups who have these ideas where
they're going and preaching hate and the
way the conducting they saw when the
general mass the non-muslims see that
they have a Dao and think that can't be
the religion of truth it's impossible
how could they be on the truth and they
are acting and behaving in this manner
so do you see it's not only what you
hear but it's also what you observe
there is those kind of doubts so when it
comes to doubts we cannot just say
doubts is only something that you hear
and you're shaken know people are more
likely emotionally and psychologically
shaken when they see things and they're
like this does not add up this does not
make sense that's the reason why as
Muslims it's very very important not
only to have knowledge but also to
conduct ourself in the best of ways
because the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him was like that the Prophet peace
upon was not known to be a man who was
angry at ill-manners ill character and
behaved in a certain way and his harsh
and angry and know he was not know for
that he was not known for that
yes there was time see where is angry
where he needed to be but he was not
known if I sit to you guys ill-mannered
harsh bad character what comes to your
mind now whoever comes to your mind that
is a problem that means that
automatically when you mentioned is
named this person or this group or this
sister this brother comes into your mind
that shows that that person has only
left that within you and that is
problematic not only to you but to the
imagine to Muslims what about the
general mass what about the non-muslims
that are watching must be monk is an
amazing example may I love mercy on him
his flock the way he behaves I've seen
no
Muslim saying to me I'm going to the
right supply event but I'm like what I'm
like what like Oprah heaven yes
non-muslims why because they look I'm
and be like look how amazing and this is
why it's so important because people
think that we should oh it's the ridge
is about tawheed of course it is but so
here is not just talking about toe heel
toe heel toe heel toe it a little bit a
little here a small so far go talking
about the three principles of tawheed oh
they honor and then mashallah buffer you
have got so he don't smash no you have
memorized something and hamdulillah it's
good but that is not just how he'd
people shits which people should see the
living toe he didn't you so they could
say you know what look how beautiful in
character this person is I want to know
the one you worship that makes you so
beautiful in character that is what we
are talking about here and believe me
actions speak louder than words much
louder so brothers and sisters before I
get into it I want you guys to listen to
this free audio clips now the reason I
bring up is when it comes to yourself is
so you can understand that certain
individuals or groups sisters or
brothers the way you conduct yourself
the damage that it can have on the
general mass let alone non-muslims
Muslims now these audio clips are on
three separate scenarios in 2016 and
2017 and auntie got in contact with me
about his younger nephew leaving the
fault of his time at 17 we went to a
talk at university of mohammed a jab and
a brother came to meet with his concerns
which you can hear for yourself yeah
about his wife and then another freak
brotherz came to speak his gonna hyde
park with their concerns yet these
principal occasions now the reason I
find that is the best time to release
this video there's all your actively so
long summer if I had some kind of a you
know feeling towards it search about
whether I could've leased out cuz they
look you go just to prove I didn't yeah
now what we want to do is listen to this
and understand why we should be careful
and why Dawa is not suitable for
everyone it's not just about oh I've got
the knowledge I can do tower brava
hikmah wisdom doing the right thing at
the right time is so key if not this is
what hap
let's watch for ourself or should I say
let's hear for ourselves and come back
and see what we can and is it fair to
say like understand and that's one of
the reasons up I love him is my proper
is that the family to me maybe it's just
I want to say he left me to leave this
LOM I'll just say maybe he's it was in
the best way of maybe his stuff was of
suitable food yes dude maybe maybe yeah
okay so you said your wife came to a
stop to it obviously would control oh
yeah yeah yeah
what's the issue now so now she's
considering what she's getting a lot
doubts because she's in the snow because
she's very harsh and because it's been
sudden because she came to slam two
years ago not all of a sudden unchanged
within these two postures he's changed
drastically so she's seen I mean I
couldn't extreme change and it's not
good for her yeah so she's going she's
saying I can't do this but literally
I'll tell you the extent that it's gone
from my wife was in that talk and you
wouldn't recognize their shoes in their
car be two weeks ago sir the club's gone
cuz because she and she the reason she
uses it she says obviously cuz so strict
I look at other people who are a little
bit less director and then I'm starting
to lose that hope like oh it may be
Islam isn't so harsh maybe we're just
making a harsh for ourselves
mmm and then obviously I told you she
doesn't have a tower that stands just
like no it's just the way that people
approach that people are taking yeah the
harshness in it it's putting the wrong
people in yeah there's a lot of the
brothers who you
now if we just change the way you see
audiences are claiming to be a scholar
you know yeah okay yeah yeah okay now
they're pushing the preservation of
exactly to come to a close over like
exposure yeah yeah now my dear brothers
and sisters you heard that for yourself
very clearly now the question that is to
be better than also that is it before
nobody can blame somebody else I live in
Islam oh I would say pressing us unfair
that's why I said that above a look it's
not fair free to come and point pinpoint
okay this brother there was a problem
there but I will also reject the notion
that it's completely someone is not
cannot play a part No
sorry how people come to Islam we play a
part in it with the permission of Allah
also we can't play a part in them
leaving Islam and just as someone come
into Islam you get rewarded for what
they do and if you cause somebody to
leave Islam course not directly directly
if you have play a part in it you will
be accountable for that so that's why
balances is really important the way we
conduct I was it was very very key and
that's why you heard it from those voice
notes why did these people feel this way
why did they all of a sudden say you
know what this was
these this person or these people were
someone that we used to listen to but
now again these were white you know what
why did they feel that because this is
why it getting it it proves my point
that doubts are just not what you hear
and be super hard and then you answer
them
some of them you go these people who
come to us and we talk to them they say
this is a superhot please there is doubt
we answer the doubt but they are still
not convinced because this there's been
something that's left with them you get
them trying to say so that's the reason
why now suggest not what you hear what
you see what you witness how you feel
that is the reason why it's so important
when you look at the Prophet sallallahu
aleyhi we sellem
his character his conduct was amazing it
was amazing the way you conducted
himself and that's the reason why before
the Companions how they conducted
themselves people run to Islam they said
we want to be like these people they saw
the living Islam in them can we say that
today can we say as Muslims today we
have that that people when they look at
us they're like we want to be Muslim no
they don't no they don't brothers and
sisters so where does this stem from
where does this come from now brothers
and sisters these people or this person
whoever these people are talking about
I'm not doubting the intentions I can
never doubt the intentions say they're
doing it for Beth that's between them
and Allah we assume the best that this
brother or the sister or this group they
want the best Abdullah bin Masood said
come read in lille highly reusable a
lots of people intended good but how
many or some didn't achieve it now
brothers and sisters what do we learn
from that it's not just intention of
saying I
I want good it doesn't work like that if
you have no knowledge basically of you
you can sure if you if you enjoy it
you're ignorant you can cure that with
knowledge but when somebody is arrogant
or for example somebody has this no
manner that's something within the
character that you have to overcome so
then going into the dour
with knowledge you have knowledge
Marshall you can call Quran Sunnah all
day all night mashallah merely increase
you in in beneficial knowledge knowledge
beneficial knowledge there's something
that people need to ask for but your
character you behave in the way you're
acting is causing a greater harm and
this happens in the park and lots of
brothers and sisters come and the way
they conduct myself brother mashallah
okay your course of Quran stand all day
happy but the way you're conducting and
behaving people are like oh honey do you
come Chauncey and this is why it's
important now let's go to the Quran
we'll go to surah al-e-imran hannam-dong
yeah verse 1 5 9 so Alice want Allah
says this look and this is something we
can learn from of life so bye bye
so by mercy from Allah o Muhammad SAW
Allah illallah wa sallam you were
lenient with them soft with them and if
he had been rude in speech and harsh in
heart they would have disbanded from you
it's part of law look at that look at I
was wanting to assist something I
thought doesn't sense why he down for
just ok yes if he was harsh with them
they would've run from you now let's
learn something now this is to Musa a
sermon is Bravo yeah all those ordering
them to go to Pharaoh
go to Pharaoh but how does that loss if
round is one of the worst creatures on
this planet
Lana - la la yeah he is the worst of
creatures now he expected a lot ago say
speak to this evil man I once speak to
this disgusting man this wretched man
look at what says go both of you to
Pharaoh Pharaoh own he has transgressed
and speak to him with harsh words
rude words no words bad words and speak
to him with gentle speech that perhaps
he may be reminded or fear Allah
brothers and sisters please understand
what I'm saying you now today we have
people groups let alone fair around to
the Muslims that are non-muslims the way
they treat the way they talk to them the
way they talk to them you look and say
AHA what the hell that like their sworn
enemies back that they sworn enemies
that is the reason why brothers and
sisters is very important for to get
involved in the dawah to give Dawa
Waialae I swear upon Allah you're a clap
your character is their main fundamental
thing one Bravo was seen yeah I heard
see there was this Prophet he done a
video he got destroyed I think was
talking about me from mistaken and he
uploaded the video cuz he had good ass
luck
just just to show us good outside what
line this is exactly my point
the fact that you're belittling a flag
when the Prophet peace be upon him said
I came for nothing but a perfect but
character shows the problem not only is
there a living proof the way you conduct
yourself Bravo not only that but also
the fact that your luck is in our took
us to his assumption that I got this
shot in argument I don't know which one
he's talking about it
but he said no he uploaded it just to
show her good character this shows that
he does not value this and son are you
you just put it out just to show good a
good character Brava
this is the whole point your manners the
way you conduct yourself do you know how
much I'm going to emphasize on it
this is the main thing people look at
your actions they do not care you can be
an arrogant guy
oh man of great quotes in Quran Sunnah
all day all night people are looking at
you I think anybody else guys harsh
ill-mannered foul shouting
Subhan Allah you guys you're doomed
you're finished you're going to hell
fire Lister if you come with the first
guys gonna say thank you
keep your Islam to yourself keep it to
yourself cause they're still a part of
it seriously we don't want nothing to do
with it people should want to come to
Islam with the way you conduct yourself
and that's why I'll give him off to men
as an example mercy on him because he
does that you can see it
so Obama sisters may Allah bless you
guys
in a ceremony better care to incha'allah
from these little sets that I made out
bring me some videos do you not forget
to subscribe to our new channel salam
studios inshallah subscribe bashar
amazing videos on those channels we were
having regular content must not show
come in where we teach the basis of the
religion to all the youngsters as well
and behind the scene footage as well
may Allah bless you guys assalamualaikum
warahmatullah better care to on the
corner this way I'm gonna this way